yes
tonight's the White House Correspondents
Dinner we are showing that crap I was
invited
so it's Trump we both said no I think
Trump said it best you may have heard I
was invited to another event tonight the
White House Correspondents Dinner
but I'd much rather be in Washington
Michigan than in Washington
very clever but just in case something
happens at the Correspondents Dinner we
actually have someone here monitoring
the event
[Applause]
[Music]
for a guy but damn this was a great week
one of the best weeks ever it's right up
there with the Miracle on Ice or when
the wall fell or or when Lou Dobbs woke
up in my basement that rascal he nod
through the restraints but it was a week
of history hugs and handshakes merci
beaucoup I liked him a lot
it's the handshake the salesman's
signature and Trump's always leaves a
bruise so how do you prepare for that if
only there were a drug well it's
official I'm gonna visit the White House
I can't believe I'm gonna meet the
president how's your hand straight hand
strength y-you see how firmly this dude
shakes hands look at what he did with
McCrone
[Music]
yeah I guess you're right sounds like
you need a stronger grip yeah but how
it's easy thanks to preparation shake
preparation shake is a blend of
cortisone and crushed up Himalayan fire
hands apply 30 times a day for three
days and watch your hand size and
strength increase exponentially you'll
be ready for any hand shake especially
with powerful world leaders wow this is
the most lotion I've ever had on my hand
I doubt that cowboy but I can feel it
working already
[Music]
thanks preparation shake I'm ready for
the White House
[Music]
so try preparation shake today you can
go from this to this warning may cause
permanent enlargement of skeletal muscle
and organs but that's that's not the
only friend that trump made this week
Kanye West's talk about brain a hip-hop
star supporting Trump is like the Pope
canonizing Freddy Krueger how did this
sheep react so now Donald Trump has two
black friends I hope ben Carson doesn't
get jealous like I don't even know what
happened here
I think Kanye West just realized he's
too rich to not be Republican I don't
even know what it is we have the right
to independent thought and I
independently think that Kanye has lost
his mind
of course the memories of grade school
you do something different and the mob
descends Kanye saw this coming but he
did it anyway as an example for others
to follow
I mean I wonder if Kanye gets it by the
way in all fairness Kanye West gets it
he got
yeah yeah you want to find the people
scared of this find the ones mocking it
and while that's happening another
handshake occurred these fellows Kim
looking great and his shirt borrowed
from Hillary this is huge it's true it's
true true yeah and who got this ball
rolling I think we'll have a meeting
over the next three or four weeks
they're going to be a very important
meeting the D nuclearization of the
Korean Peninsula one of the fake news
groups this morning what do you think
President Trump had to do with it I'll
tell you what Mike how about everything
[Laughter]
so good everyone should be happy but
then being happy means you got to admit
that Trump made you happy not smiling
over this
that's the ultraviolet black light that
reveals a childish hate I wonder what
Katie Couric was covering in this
nondescript building I have an
appointment with harmony the world's
first sex robot what do you like to do
for fun I like computers and making new
friends I also love making love to you
well what look I get it how many times
can we watch the same people being
interviewed James Comey stormy Daniels
leave it to Katie to land an interview
with a sex robot but they ordered a
salad for her what a waste of $18.00
speaking of robots back to that
Correspondents Dinner what a segue so
this year who's the emcee someone from
The Daily Show who was last year's emcee
someone from The Daily Show who will be
next year's emcee someone from The Daily
Show so you can forecast the whole thing
a comic tells a joke you could see a
mile away and the audience will pretend
to be shocked it's as predictable as a
question from John Carl
mr. president what if I'm Michael Cohen
are are you considering a thank you very
much
[Music]
stupid question but this is why Kanye
feels so dangerous and Trump unlike
anything else and leave it to Trump to
once again counter-program with his own
rally what a great comparison to the
Correspondents Dinner I mean look at the
dinner it's like a timeshare
presentation at a retirement village and
look at the rally it's Club Med on
clothing-optional nights one is
soul-destroying but the other is a lot
of fun so this is a new era it feels
like a rip in the universe Kanye and
Trump Kim and moon the media doesn't get
it but you do bubbles are bursting and
beliefs are upended if this is what
happens after sleeping with a porn star
let's welcome tonight's guest he's so
wise owls come to him for advice host of
the radio show dr. Tru midday live dr.
Drew Pinsky he's some man with the plan
who's never had a tan Fox News radio
host Tom salut
she thought Silence of the Lambs was a
romantic comedy
Naza review reporter catch him he's
considered a giant among Giants WWE
Superstar my massive sidekick Tyrus all
right bro you claim to be a doctor all
right
interested in the psychological effects
of Trump winning on the visceral Trump
hater yeah the the cognitive dissonance
that's gonna occur in other words when
people believe that they believe deeply
that this man is incapable of nothing
good if something good comes out of it
they either have to deny he had anything
to do with it right or there were as you
said the bubble burst their world rips
in half and what they will begin looking
for is a scapegoat right they will have
to gather their aggression as a group
and scapegoat somebody my fear is it
could be somebody like Hillary I wish
you can see they've been scaping to her
right along yeah and that could really
get very aggressive yeah they will there
are so many off ramps Ted saying Trump
might be a good person or not mid note
he doesn't have to be a good person no
you could be a great president but they
take they choose the off ramps they have
to go somewhere else they can't it does
not fit their Condor they're watching a
movie that that you know they're
watching a different movie than you and
I are yes they're watching a movie with
stormy Daniels in it that's right the
one that you watched pay-for-view by the
way $18 at your local Marriott hey Tom
North Korea pretty big deal huge news
Greg huge news huge news for the whole
world and the interesting thing was that
that peep world people who watch world
politics had to admit that it was
unprecedented and amazing so I loved
watching cable news because there was
this phenomena if you remember Fonzie
couldn't say wrong he did say wrong they
they were having trouble giving the
president credit they're like president
Trump definitely deserves cruel
[Laughter]
I get it I get it
if it was such an extraordinary things
our lifetime are you kidding did you
ever expect this no no no but that's why
he does things where he up ends the
table then he starts at a negotiating
process from chaos and it tends to work
I want to ask you about Kanye he upset a
lot of people did he upset you no no and
all the people getting so upset made me
very happy because I got to feel better
than that yes
think about it think about having the
time and energy to actually get this mad
over this you need a life yes that kind
of time energy I'm serious go home hug
your family take up fly-fishing do
something because that is very very
pathetic it is it is although I was very
excited by it so does that mean I need
to get a life probably well that's to
hear it neither here nor there yeah that
is true I already knew that yes yes
all right Tyrus you have strong feelings
you do think Kanye did this to promote
something well first of all going back
to your point about all this came from
sleeping with a porn star yeah we
probably all should sleep at porn stars
that was my point yes I know you're
upset so what that's I'm more upset at
the narrative yeah that there's this
shocking misnomer that a brother
african-american could like Donald Trump
like Kanye was the first one like he was
Pro Trump great yeah move on it's not a
big deal yeah a lot of black people
voted for president Trump a lot they did
not all vote for Hillary Clinton not how
it works and the narrative that is
played
we had an amazing historic moment it's
like the wall coming down this is
something that in the history books will
be at least two chapters yeah North and
South Korea are on the same side and the
narrative is oh let's get people black
people in Trump again let's get a racial
thing going that is what drives me nuts
and Kanye of course he's a perfect guy
for that because he's not political if
you asked him hey what's your favorite
part about Trump's oh I don't know he
doesn't even know he didn't vote he did
this when he was elected he was like I
didn't vote but if I would have voted I
would vote for Trump he does it for
reacts
to make it worse the next was it today
I'm got a song coming out now about it I
guess it's hard to be that brother don't
represent brothers he doesn't he's him
it's part of that Kardashian world where
they do things for attention and it's
very cool right now to say hey I'm cool
with Trump cuz the left because the left
it's it's the new it's the new rebel
okay it's the new it's the new villain
I'm a bad guy I like Trump and then the
left nut and you get two new cycles yeah
you get a ton of attention
everybody's like damn I'm mad that I was
supportive in the beginning I should
have waited I'm deeply disturbed by what
they're saying about Kanye this angry
because he's contemplating political
views they don't agree with he lost his
mind yeah hey he's been public about
having had a psychiatric condition so
you're stigmatizing him write a B and
anybody else that has a kind of
psychiatric condition if you don't agree
with their ideas you have to stigmatize
somebody like Lee and then number two
since when is it that changing political
views or contemplating political views
is a sign and symptom of psychiatric
illness give me a damn break
yeah we're pathologizing they are not
even put thought they even know what
they're doing that's the problem they're
throwing it but we're talking about
Kanye West instead of kim jeong-hoon
that's the problem I think they're both
monumental in different ways one is in
our culture and one is in world
geopolitics and they're both kind of
groundbreaking did your politics thing
obviously as a bigger story but the fact
that Kanye is urging people to step out
of the boxes of right in the left
anti-trump proton we're we are in a
society where everybody is being put in
buckets or boxes and he's saying don't
be in a bucket don't be in a box I think
that's important as a pop culture
evolution it's not
they already stepped out the box that's
why we have Donald Trump as president
yeah that's the point they push this
narrative like we're all in boxes we're
not we're only on if you watch CNN
during the little panels and they talk
about all the trouble on the streets but
if you actually go on the streets I
travel the world I'm in the airports and
I've yet to have
although I'm a giant I get it yeah yeah
they have somebody to run up to me hey
Uncle Tom what you're doing on Fox News
hey man good job brother well you keep
telling how it really is that's not the
real narrative it's not exciting or
surprising brothers like Trump how many
others there try there's a whole bunch
of them these are more than five yeah I
mean it's that's yeah it's not it's not
real
[Applause]